[Music]
don't be a fake
don't be a flake don't run away from
your feelings babe don't be afraid don't
be ashamed don't hesitate to say hey
babe
hey babe hey babe hey
hey babe don't be
afraid take a bad
pot and make it better
remember to
hey babe i'm sorry i didn't get it right
i don't know what the song is
what's this what's the song all right
we're about to start i say let's do uh
let's do hey jude that's it he's one of
the hay's already in there you said
great how does that go
yeah i said it's hey jude it's arguably
the most famous song by the beatles
right the beatles being arguably the
most famous band of all time the beatles
i've heard of
yeah but then hey jude you and then you
said listen just start i'll start
singing and you'll follow along
and and i was holding your hand to that
one yeah i didn't um
i didn't i think i've heard the song
is it let me ask you a question hey jude
i mean that was the flattest i'm not
saying i got the pipes of uh
paul mccartney but but okay hey
so nah nah nah nah nah nah nah
maybe we just start off with
[Music]
and that's beatles that was one of their
you think the their biggest song
arguably i'd say at least uh
recognizable
yeah yeah i mean i don't want to argue
with you about it names and beetle songs
yellow submarine
um okay i want to hold your hand yes
let it be yes
let it be i want to hold your hand
yellow submarine
walking across abbey road or something
heavy road
yeah yeah yeah they're walking across oh
yeah that's the album cover yeah
uh you know so many though you know
there's like i think they they have like
they have they have very con like most
of their songs are hits they have very
few songs that weren't like
made an impact with people god at least
whereas like someone like zeppelin or
the stones let's say right they're
committed to the stones a lot right the
stones have a
massive catalog and they have a lot of
hits but they have a lot of also songs
that probably like b-sides and extra
things that we have where i think the
beatles are a little bit more efficient
in their hits and
maybe i'm speaking out of turn but this
is what i do no i don't think he's
speaking out of turn
yeah but i just don't know that beatles
is one of those things where i
i do feel a little insecure about
because i'm like everybody's all about
the beatles and i'm not
did you go away to college you did i no
i didn't went to saint joseph's college
you know
brooklyn i commuted i was a commuter
okay is that the big is that the big
issue
i think when you come when you go away
to college i think like
the all the people i've ever met that
want to go to college end up expanding
their
you know they're like their musical
catalog right you know they come back
and
you know between uh depending on where
you went
you're doing all your shrooms and your
weed and you're listening to the
everything from the beatles to zeppelin
to
pink floyd to oh jesus like things like
dave matthews band and stuff like that
you know that dave i never i don't
really know
i know but i only know he said he wakes
up and uh is that
what he's dave matthews bad i just don't
crash into me
isn't it isn't that he wakes up in the
powder spring
and the dangers are bright and brings
hands on fair fashion
it's nothing matthews
right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yes i
don't know then
i know you know the song right here
isn't that a whole genre of rock they do
that like college rock or something like
that or
did i make this up google this and see i
don't know if i if i dreamt this or i
actually saw this on tv
is there a band or a guy that plays
all beetle songs with his feet and calls
himself the fetals
[Laughter]
or did i did i really hope so i might i
don't
really hope so google defeated i really
hope so
the fetals the beatles no the the
beatles
what's the fetals at the fetals oh
the beatles quotes and more things but
does he do it with his feet
he hasn't posted since april of 2020.
the fetals of
april 22 the fetals the fetals i thought
maybe i had nobody but but pimp you got
to put feet
f.e.a beetles get it like the beat like
did you know that
what do you like for the longest time it
didn't occur to me
like obviously beetle actual beetle is
spelled b-e-t-l-e
like a beetle like a yes right beetle
but the beatles
or b-e-a-t-l-e-s and i think that has to
do with like
beat the beat like the back beat like
the beat
so the beatles so the beat and beatles
makes beetles
interesting so fetals would have to be
fva
otherwise you're spelling it wrong yeah
well we've know we've gotten to know
you know from doing the podcast with him
for so long is he cannot spell
correctly can i actually admit something
i had a subtitle billy joel
talk about the beatles and i spelled it
wrong
yeah actually there are usually um
so many misspellings on all of our
videos
but i i find it endearing i find it a
daring i guess i play a little game
i play a little game like almost like
the misspellings are like a little
waldo's
yeah yeah and i try to sell them but
what i do appreciate about the homeless
pimp is that a lot of these a lot of
people now a lot of other podcasts or
people that want a subtitle are just
using the automated
subbing yeah we go old school pimp's a
mom and pop shop
he does it i do it at 6am so
at 6am by hand on edibles most likely um
speaking speaking of edibles new sign
yeah
look at the new sign look at this sign
shout out ted mundy
right or is it ted bundy ted um no it's
10 months
10 months 10 months on instagram 10
months instagram go follow atta
ted muns mosaic art
t-e-d m-u-n-z-m-o
pit maybe you could put it up um you
know when the ups comes out but this
ted muns mosaic art made another banging
sign he does the signs for most of the
podcast
this hey babe sign unbelievable thank
you so much i like sal's elbow to me it
does look like a vagina with a slight
opening
yeah yeah it looks like a slight vaginal
opening on his elbow
which i think fits photos because that's
my elbows do have
that's realistic you have a you have a
dim you have an elbow
opening elbows you have chicken dish you
have vaginitis to the elbow
vaginal opening elbows s v
o e that's what it is svo can i say
this will hang soon it's leaning if
you're not listening
if you're not watching and you're
listening it's leaning on the couch and
onto the wall but it's because
the mosaics weigh like 50 pounds or
something like that and i can't just hit
put it into the sheetrock or it'll
collapse on us
so i had to reinforce the whole thing i
i bought a stud finder
right i borrowed a stud finder and you
you go across the thing and it beeps
when you know there's a stud behind it
that's what it is
now what i have to do is i have to take
a 2x4 and i have to nail it long ways
into two studs and then we nail this
into the two by four on the wall so it's
a bit of a project
a little bit project yeah and guess
where you can see that project
patreon.com oh yeah patreon is the only
way you're gonna see me doing
lights yes construction work around the
house yes
like construction work around the house
at pace it's not work you're worth your
five or ten bucks i don't know what it
is at the page and also
uh christy comedy.com i got live stand
updates we added a second show at the
fox theater
october 23rd if you want to go get
tickets christy comedy.com
the only tickets left available are
eatontown new jersey in august i think
maybe a few tickets in pittsburgh in
october and nashville tennessee
the rest of these shows baby are sold
out so thank you guys so much
oh we have a new clips page hey babe
clips page yes
we have a new hey babes clips page and
that is going to have
little nuggets of shows that you can
share and laugh at not having to watch
the whole episode
yeah it's almost like the chapters of
the episode and guess what babe
july 8th my show on true tv called
backyard bar wars comes out and it's
going to start right after your
impractical joker's episode because i
just had to do all the promo reads and i
had to say about a million times
stay right here uh thanks for watching
that episode of impractical jokers
my brand new show backyard bar war
starts now
when is it 10 july 8th 10 30 p.m yours
is 10 p.m
in practical jokers we come after you
but is mine a new episode or no
it's a new epi weapon oh it is cause
we're off the air right now so is that
is that our first
day back too that i don't know
that i don't know yeah but i'm just
saying
that's that's july 10th yeah um
um july 8th it starts july 8th all right
i'll be there it's appointment
television for me yes there it is i
can't wait are you going to have a
little viewing party
why don't i can't do a viewing why don't
we do a live stream
why don't we do a live stream we'll do
like a mystery science theater
like me and you live stream watching it
live and we'll
we'll we'll and we'll just we'll just
talk about it and we'll you know we'll
say what we like what we don't like
can we do that we can come to town to do
that
right here stream it right there and
then we can put it up and i don't know i
don't know the only way that i would
ever do that
is is with you like us like just maybe
like our family i would
never sell in a million years ever
in my life throw myself a viewing party
a public viewing party for
anything i've ever done the amount of
embarrassment that comes with that
is next level i do not do a viewing
party well i know like usually the
club's doing for us but like
when your comedy central hour came out
no
no no you had to have a view no no
i know i i just i don't want it to me
it just feels like now these people are
being forced to laugh if they don't
laugh
it's excruciating i'd rather just be
home with
you me and you do it that's one thing
because we can make fun of everything
and it's we're in our element
but to be there i that's the last thing
i ever want to do yeah is a viewing
party for and i don't care what i
don't care if i became president of the
united states i would never want to view
it i wouldn't want a viewing party of
the inauguration yeah
yeah cause you just get you're judging
every little thing yeah and i i don't
like it have you guys ever gone to a bad
viewing party it was like awkward oh so
many
where it's like what do you do what's
the etiquette of i don't know man it's
just like you just you know you just try
to
pick a couple of positives or or or just
leave
you know i forgot the show it was some
show where like people were like naked
strangers it wasn't naked and afraid it
was like a spin-off of that for i
believe
bravo and i got invited to the viewing
party and i was sitting in the back and
rupaul was there and about
10 minutes into i believe a 45-minute
episode he got up
and like got like his point he was like
i can't even do this no more
i swear to god and he walked out and he
walked out but like made it
known that like i'm not leaving because
i have an emergency the bathroom it's
because of the show
yeah and it was a brutal show it was
very like self-serving like we're naked
like
it was kind of like not great but i was
like it's a little ridiculous i mean
just wait another 35 minutes they gave
us free popcorn with cbd
yeah yeah i remember like because
sometimes i'll go to movie premieres
and if they're not good we sneak out i
hated mine i was going to say what about
your own movie from here
my skin was crawling during the whole
you hated the whole thing well yeah i
don't loved it well it was like you
you're battling these emotions right
right you have a movie in theaters holy
[ __ ] you did that wow yeah
my family's there it's like a show out
of a dream come true at the same time
though
i'm so insecure i know all the things i
didn't like about my
the movie all the things i would change
and i couldn't change yeah and i had to
sit there
with all my friends loved ones
colleagues people i respect
and there's some good moments there's
some not good moments
so for me i it's a dual experience
one is like i almost want to cry because
i'm hearing my parents in a movie
theater and i have a movie out but i
almost want to also cry
because i am completely insecure
embarrassing and i'm focusing on all the
things i hate about the movie
i will tell you i will tell you that's
i've been to three movie premieres
and i've been to a lot of movies in the
theater
i never in my life been a part of a
movie
yeah uh uh uh been at a movie premiere
or been in a movie just watching on my
own
that got the amount of laughter at the
height high moments
that that i've like when you hit big
in the movie the laughter was insane it
was like being at a comedy special
and i saw wedding crashers you know when
it came out with my friends i saw old
school i saw movies that i have
but and we would laugh of course but not
like i'm talking about falling out of
the chair
at the high moment that's nice of you
that's nice yeah yeah i thought it would
be even better yeah well i mean we all
do but that but i'm not saying that that
yes those things that you probably
interpreted as huge last i
probably maybe was hoping would be well
you saw it 10 000 times i would assume
before we saw it
i never saw any of it yeah i i just
remember being like uh
i all i focused on was the places that i
hated that didn't get less that i knew
could have been different
yeah you know that's why like it's no
one's real like real fault but if we
ever got to do a movie again
yeah we would only do it if we could
control it yeah completely and control
the edit and control everything
because it nets out to like it's a lot
of people like at the
in the show we're doing it completely on
our like no one's really
interfering much with the movie it was
passing through a lot of people and it
gets deluded
you know jokes are all about the timing
the cuts does it the takes the way up to
500 takes argued over which is the best
take what's the best line was the best
punchline
so uh it netted out to be something that
i had to watch and kind of be like ugh
i remember after being at the after
party being at the buffet line standing
in between waiting to get a i believe it
was a ham and cheese sandwich
waiting uh in between paula abdul and
brook shields i was sandwiched
between the both of them and i was like
yeah i'm not supposed to be here
didn't you get it off a paul abdullah i
did hit off with paul abdul i did hit
off i was 100 single at the time
i did hit it off at uh with paul out i
didn't mean you did anything wrong i
just
oh yeah like conversationally no
conversation we did conversation we did
and then uh and then um and then yeah
and then i hit it off with paul abdul
and then i never heard from her again
but i might have went too heavy on the
techs did you exchange some texts i sent
no i i sent texts i did not receive it
yeah straight up yeah so what did you
text her
i forgot it was something like great
meeting you at the party or
you know so i may have said something
extremely corny like
a line from her songs or something like
that do you remember the worst text
message you've ever sent to someone
um i know we got a taste of sows last
time
did i tell you about that was shaq david
blaine oh no
when you read the twitter messages the
worst text i ever sent
i embarrassingly texted shaq once too
you texted shaq
yeah like his personal cell yeah
and he never responded no he did he did
well it's i think i did not tell the
story no
texting shaq that's the name of the
episode i definitely
i've definitely publicly told it before
uh continue with yours first though well
no i don't remember what i sent to i
don't remember what the text i sent to
paul abdullah i just know i didn't
receive
a text back but i remember sending three
maybe five texts to her
[Laughter]
because two of them were i'm not trying
to god i just choked on my peanut butter
because
an hour ago because i know shout out to
peanut butter you know what
sorry dogs which by the way here's the
thing here's the thing
the other thing cause i've never when
you put two people with adhd together
it's in it's literally impossible here
look because we got the jebe peanut
butter
which is white chocolate almond with
blueberries and then we got
the butterscotch peanut butter um the
taste buds peanut butter which is the
butterscotch peanut butter
now i haven't tried them yet and what i
wanted to ask from you saw why i want to
bring this up is because i wanted to ask
you
okay because you have tried them you've
actually been through a couple of
jars of them yeah already i went through
my first set they're mini jars
and now i'm on my second yeah
and they're also not that bad for you i
mean we only got 161 cows and two
tablespoons
um uh uh six grams of protein pro pro
no cholesterol which is great almost
five grams of sugar
nothing no if you compare that to other
peanut butters that's like literally i
mean it's
so good so low sugar low cow
high protein no no yopeanut.com now let
me ask you a question
i'm talking about if you had to pick one
i'm talking about i have a loaded gun
finger on the trigger to your temple i
pull this your head's going to blow
clean off
you're done you're dead do and but you
but you have to pick one you're going
yeah yeah
yeah okay i have a gunshot so you can't
say bolt is what i'm saying is if
you say both i'm gonna pull the trigger
but i use them for different purposes
but mike mike here's my thing no sal if
you just give me one answer
then i pull the gun away i pull the gun
away
and that's it and it's no problems but
if i catch you
if i catch you with the jar of peanut
butter that you didn't pick in the house
or on your person
i'll shoot you in the head immediately
i'm all over the floor i'm talking about
i not even think twice pulled the gun
out you're gonna like
johnny like me you're gonna come shout
out johnnydeck.com go buy a bat
shoot shout out you know shout out
organization
shout out organization you know shout
out organization shout out being in
charge of your life being controlled yes
yeah shout out staples they have a lot
of organizing products they do have a
good organizing product shout out
staples if they'd like to be a sponsor
uh you they can email you a gun yes
shout out organized crime careful back
full back yeah staples you can go ahead
and email alex at paragon
yeah um so
so what so i'm talking about a gun chad
and don't feel pressure that i'm on the
hey babe
rapper i know you wouldn't but i just
want to clarify but i do also have a gun
to your head so there is a little
pressure right
okay well just one like our hey babe
flavor is
almond butter with uh with dried
blueberries and white chocolate yes
and all those flavors comes through at
certain points it's not just in your
face
and it's good it's what i would probably
use for the peanut butter and jelly
sandwich i would make
okay the butterscotch i don't think i'd
use for peanut butter and jelly quickly
let me cut your tree just real quick
peanut butter just put on ezekiel bread
or whole wheat i love a good zeke
zeke english muffin or ezekiel toast i'm
going english muffin english muffin
meats every bread for me
even an ezekiel english muffin i never
heard of that
you've never heard of ezekiel english
[ __ ] in ezekiel not an ezekiel
english muff
oh my god they got cinnamon raisin
ezekiel english muffins they got
they got i've been having this new thing
it's like uh like a new england english
muffin or something like that
it's a little bit different i found have
you ever had one of these no they're
like
thick and they are they don't have all
the nooks and crannies like how that
thomas
does right it's like more flat but it's
dense
and chewy in the middle and crunchy on
the outside
unbelievable yeah how many calories in
one month i don't know
over two i i no no no not over two
i wouldn't do that i wouldn't be able to
do it i need 100 to 150 on the bread
and that's that's it that's it because
you want to you want to put
those calories on what's in between the
bread yes yeah yes okay so the gun's
still to your head right now
so which one is it going to be can you
at least tell me
what i would be using it for because as
derosa points out a scoop of house on
some vanilla ice cream slap your mother
in the chops
i i what you'll be using it for is i'm
just gonna say your day to day
[Laughter]
day to day i'm gonna go hours because i
can't do the butter the butter scotch is
more of a treat what i think is a little
bit
more like different than the norm it's
probably the butterscotch
i'm not answering your question in my
head my mouth is all over the floor
no well no not yet because you're saying
butterscotch is outside the box
but for the day to day every day you'll
go with hours
so taste buds butterscotch is more of a
treat yeah hey babe
white well almond with the with the
blueberries more of a day today more of
it's more practical yeah okay yeah yeah
okay so if i didn't give you the answer
you needed no but you gave me
you gave me enough i'll say this you
gave me your life you gave me enough to
save your life
okay with that fair enough yeah so you
know but listen
i i still i've taken the gun away but
it's still gonna pull a gun on you have
you ever seen a gun in a threatening
manner
you know no no no not even like
you know when you know sometimes in the
movies where they just lift up this
shirt a little bit to show you they got
one there
and they just like you don't know won't
be none you ever see that
no no i actually never have i've
actually never i don't know that i've
ever been in the room with an illegal
gun
i don't know you i'm thinking about it
and i don't think so but i i've
definitely seen like
a cop and like an irish bar take that
gun out oh well that i've seen
that i've seen but it's scary because
johnny light even said shooting
someone's the easiest thing you could do
yeah people don't [ __ ] because because
he said when you just pull the trigger
when you pull the trigger of a gun he
you know he said that's easier than
hitting someone or knifing someone so he
said anyone can pull a trigger
because it's kind of like you
disconnected from it like yeah sure you
know i mean yeah you could potentially
just kill someone but it's like you know
what do you think about um like would
you would you
be able to shoot someone like in the leg
i don't mean in a criminal sense
self-defense right you gotta
if i had like a a gun from like dick's
sporting goods or something
yeah like just you know like not like
not like a glock or anything like that
but like if i just had something like
you know if someone broke into the house
or something like that would you be able
to shoot him i would just i would shoot
for the legs without hesitation i would
shoot for the legs i think what would
happen
if i'm being honest i'd shoot for legs
and wind up shooting him in the head and
killing them
just because of a blind shot but i would
i actually oh if i was a police officer
i know
you're not supposed to aim you're
supposed to shoot to kill i believe that
they're told that or just
or hit hit this biggest center of mass
which is like the stomach
and chest that's we're supposed to aim
for but i think i would probably
i'd aim for people's legs i'd shoot
somebody in the foot yeah
just to slow them down for toes i i
tried to i tried shooting the foot
if you die from a gunshot wound to the
foot you deserve to die
it's on you yeah what are you doing
dying from a foot woman i would agree
you're talking about these people that
get shot and like they're okay like
finney cent yeah he said that nine times
yeah where did those bullets go in him
that that they're missing
all sorts of things in there i mean if
like there's there should really be
scientifically and biologically
only like really small right
areas of the body there's only a couple
that where you can shoot clean through
and you miss everything important in
there right
how is he getting shot nine times and
the bullet is missing
every single thing vital organ i don't
know
i i got two stories i got one one of my
cousins was shot in the spine
um uh and has a bullet still in his
spine still they cannot remove it they
said it's too risky and they told him at
all cause to avoid yoga
that's what he was told because he said
any type of massive flexibility in the
spine
could move the bullet and at any moment
he's living with the bullet and spine at
any moment
he could do a type of movement and the
bullet can hit on his spinal cord
and like i guess shredded or he doesn't
want to get a he can't
well the surgeons won't remove it
they're like it's too risky you might as
well just take your chances now
and see if your body hardens around it
and this way you always have the bullet
in the spine if we go in there and open
up your spine we could
d do to human error nick your spinal
cord and then you're a paraplege
whoa the second story my grandfather
used to tell a story about a man he was
in world war ii with
paraplegic is nothing from the
depends legs or the
quadriplegic means you have no function
of your arms or legs
meaning like c7 quad one two three four
exactly
paraplegic i believe you can use either
your arms or your legs
legs and lower body yes so if you're
going to be a pleage
if you want to i mean the better of the
the least the worst of the two yeah
because it's only the legs
right okay right so yeah you'd like
you'd like you know
yeah but i would think we were far along
in medicine where they could be like
let's get in there and get this
they're getting close to it now to be
honest like i think right now
people who are um spinal cord victims or
have some type of you know
neural disease where they have you know
they've become paralyzed in one
part of their body i believe not all of
them but there are people alive that are
going through that right now that will
walk and use their limbs
in their lifetime because this is what
you spoke you would be in you would be
in this career you'd be in someone who
was a paraplegic and then working their
way
or i guess paraplegic there's no
reversing but right but someone has
temporary paralysis but they need to do
a lot of work like in the movies there's
a montage yes
yes you know maybe i'd be part of the
montage yes the sickest one i've ever
seen so this might be a little scary the
sickest one i've ever seen well i was
like
holy [ __ ] this is in the course of two
weeks you have to understand in two
weeks
14 days 14 days 14 american days
this guy again i want to just put a
little
you know preface preface right here a
little flag to say go ahead
there it is pull it down um a little
pref to say
little disclaimer this doesn't have
disclaimers
shout out to disclaimer they're just
helping people say things
yeah for years now for years yeah just
shout out caveats shout out qualifiers
absolutely shout out post post scripts
post scripts
big ones asterisk please
he he was fine normal he got a flu shot
which
this doesn't happen on all flu shot this
is the minority minority minority
minority minority
but he got a flu shot this guy was fully
active he used to play soccer or
whatever
but not professionally just like you
know in a league in a men's league i
don't know why he didn't even
bring that up he was a fully active guy
that played soccer once in a while like
just adults do
right but he he like you have to work
like
your neighborhood and you probably go
down to the the address in his night
games his early morning weekend games he
did something like that did something
like that
didn't need to mention at all because
not like he was professional soccer
player you have practices
no he said did he play in school and he
was just doing this to keep it in his
life yeah yeah
yeah and and and to further more he
actually never even told me
he played in men's soccer league he was
just from argentina so i assumed okay
so yeah because he i just assume he's
he's a guy in his 20s from argentina he
probably played soccer
with his friends after work no doubt no
doubt yeah argentina
yeah so so he gets the flu shot
okay next day wakes up it's a thing
called guillain-barre
syndrome which sometimes happens
when by the time we saw him fully
paralyzed fully only had use of his
oculomotor nerve his eyes it's called
locked in syndrome
his mind and brain 100 percent untouched
like as if it happened to me and you
well we could be who we are
and then all you can do is use your eyes
to communicate
locked in syndrome it's called because
everything in your body it's a
phenomenon everything in your body
everything in your brain is 100 fine but
you can only use your oculomotor nymphs
cranial nerves 3 which we which we
talked about last week or a couple
episodes ago
where he could communicate with his eye
so he we would say
you know you know do you want food he
would go
yes and he had a laser that we could
focus with his eyes it was like a thing
and he would write yes there's no coming
out of that
ready for this oculum guillain-barre
syndrome
there's you roll the dice with gb
guillain-barre
is something that can either stick with
you forever
or go fully back to 100 the way you were
one morning i came in he was up on his
feet
kidding walking around like that just
didn't happen
so for two weeks locked down and not
knowing if that was going to be for the
rest of his life
we had no answers came in one day and he
was i came in one day being like ready
to ask some questions so
he hit the i board he gave me a high
five and was just up walking around
what do you do did you embrace him did
you start crying i said like a miracle
i said rodrigo you're up and he goes
yeah he goes i woke up today
and he goes i was praying with my eyes
to the lord
and he said i was you know thinking
about the lord and asking him to just
let me walk
and he said my mother flew in he goes my
mother landed at jfk
and the nurse just told me coach why
don't you fly
i think i want to say coach only because
because he was from
all the way from well no only because he
was 27 years old and again not no knock
on him but he had
he did talk about he had a roommate so i
would assume if you have a roommate at
27 years old you're not at the point
first class
if i would have known that he was going
to get up out of what i would have i
mean i was a physical therapist i don't
know that would have necessarily been
able to maybe you could
go fund me for a first class for the
mother or give him an extra leg room for
sure i mean to fly from argentina
yeah you just want at least a coach plus
yeah i mean
you know she came granted she just want
to get on the first flight you know all
of a sudden her son can only use his
eyes
yeah so i would assume she'd just get on
the first flight but if she knew that
eventually you'd get i'd like her to be
in comfort
yeah you know going over the atlantic
ocean though a lot of people think jfk
is the place to fly into when they come
here new workers
even newark right but continue you're in
and out yeah
so he woke up and he could fully use his
body the guillain-barre
we didn't do we did nothing but theron
beret although it's
tragic has a real ring to it it does
yeah it sounds like a real fancy french
guy that just sleeps with a lot of women
it's one of the nicer
it's one of the and to be honest with
you he got berated he got berated
and for quite often in physical therapy
school when somebody
would be wearing a berets are you
wearing a guillain beret
is that a guillotine right um you know
and so
so here we go august 6 1941 six-year-old
elaine esposito went to the hospital for
a routine appendectomy she went
under general anesthetic and never came
out dubbed the sleeping beauty esposito
stayed in a coma for 37 years and 111
days before succumbing in 78
the longest ever coma so nothing to do
with guillain-barre pimp just wanted to
make it sadder
so she is the guinness
i mean not for nothing guinness if
you're watching and we know you are
do we need to put records on the longest
coma is there anything that we need to
do
yeah i mean the ladies already in a coma
thirty seven years you don't have to be
like
you were the best that comes yeah did
her family get a plaque for that yeah
you know what i mean or maybe she wants
to maybe she's like look
i got nothing going on speaking of
blacks baby
look at that youtube 100k
100k we got the youtube plaque to the no
pressure network take it out of the
place okay all right
do it there we go wow look and it's got
a mirror in it
i can see your face thank you so much
youtube a hundred thou
yeah what are they i mean you think
they're just firing these off of the
conveyor belt line right i mean i got to
be honest
a lot of people have a hundred thou i
think once we start if we get to 500
down now we're starting to be in rare
air okay
rarer air 100 now but here's the thing
magic spoon it's like a lot of these ad
copies you gotta look at the ad cop you
gotta
throw it for me magic spoon you don't
even know so i don't even need it it's
i'm telling you right now it's the best
cereal
i've ever had in my life okay it's keto
friendly
it's got no sug it's got like 14 grams
of protein 140 calories a serving
i eat it all the time with almond banana
milk my kids eat it
i eat it dry i eat it wet i literally i
go to the gym sometimes and forget to
take my protein shake and i eat magic
spoon
i i dude i did an ad for it for a gender
reveal party for one of my children
i threw magic spoon my my girlfriend
threw magic spoon at me because she was
like i know you love this more than you
love your kids
yeah yeah i mean you are really i mean i
don't think you've loved anything more
than you love magic magicspoon.com hey
babe use the promo code hey babe get
five dollars off your first order i know
it all inside and out
because i myself do it magic spoon
doesn't even send me product anymore
because i said you're too
insane yeah so they make me do it and i
don't care magicspoon.com
hey babe use the promo code hey babe the
new cereal the cinnamon
one the one that tastes like cinnamon
toast crunch yeah it's sal
i don't think you understand how good it
is just bury your head in the box it's
unbelievably good yeah unbelievable and
i'll be
i'll be honest with you right now i like
all the flavors frosted
chocolate the cocoa blueberries the
honey nut one
i like don't love don't love i'm gonna
be honest with you
every other and you may love the honey
nut go ahead do it i'm just want to be
honest with you
but the cereal itself every other flavor
including hunting up but just not as
much as the other ones
it's the best show i've ever had if i
don't have it i get a little upset
i i already i have to go back to life
for two weeks i've already sent it
to andrew santino's house have it when
you wake up so i have it and santino
said there's a box of magic spoon here
for you i said santino you touch it and
i'll shave your red
now right don't touch my sears yeah yeah
yeah magic spoon it's mine
magicspoon.com
hey babe tao as always this podcast
sponsored by better health that's right
is there something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals
no uh yes i meant to say yes but
yes there was but if there is if you are
someone where there is no but there was
but it's okay you don't have to have
that no but stop but the reason why i so
quickly said no
the reason why so quickly is you've been
using better help
yeah because i've been using better help
and it's been assessing my needs and it
matched me so
this is serious truthfully you know it's
all online it's on over zoom i do it
over zoom
the therapist that i've connected with
over zoom is like
legitimately like i believe going to be
a lifelong friend like he's helped me
and my family through so much stuff
you know because you know whatever
covert crisis and other things that like
legit like
it's my boy now like i invite him to
comedy shows and he says legally i can't
wow yeah well let's tell them a little
bit more about what this is okay okay so
no i'm serious it's professional
counseling done securely online it's not
a crisis line
right it's not self-help but they help
you assess your needs and match you with
a licensed professional therapist
and you can start communicating with
under 48 hours yes which is true
yeah broad range of expertise available
too so it's not just one specific thing
no and many are may not be locally
available in your area
no because it's online you can reach
therapists that you wouldn't necessarily
have access to
if you weren't the service is available
for clients worldwide right you can log
into your account anytime send a message
to your counselor and you'll get a
timely and thoughtful
response yeah better help want you to
start living a happier life today yes
and and for our listeners right now and
i swear this is this is one of the
this is one of the things that we read
where i actually think damn this might
like be making a difference for people
like it's it for you it is no
it really it truly does and if you right
now if you go to betterhelp that's
help.com
hey babe okay so here's what you're
going to do you're going to go to
betterhelp that's help dot com
slash hey babe and you're going to get
10 off your first month which is a nice
nice nice savings especially if
you know money's a little tight right
now i know and then you get you just
feel better and brighter about yourself
you go out and then you exude confidence
you probably start to look better like
you got a shirt now a beautiful floor
and and you probably wouldn't wore that
shirt when you were feeling gloomy no
because you know what
i was talking to my therapist on better
hope the other day he said chris it's
time to blossom
i said boom putting on the flower shark
that's exactly what you're doing
betterhelp.com
slash hey babe 10 off the first month
can't beat it
how many people on youtube have a
hundred
how many accounts have a hundred
thousand subscribers so you look that up
i i mean that's like googling how many
millionaires are in the united states
how about how many youtube channels have
over 100 000 subscribers around
230 000 youtube channels so many
that's so many 230
000 channels have over 100 000 but how
many youtube
ch channels how many youtube channels
are there
oh wow we don't get a plaque again until
we reach a mill
so we get silver for a hundred to a 500
they skip over
that's a big gap it's a little
ridiculous too because it's like
you're gonna send out a hundred thirty
230 hundred thousand
but not anything for the fives right
it's weird
yeah how many youtube 31 million youtube
channels
wow so 230 000 out of 31 million i
thought i had a lot of cable channels i
have like a thousand
thirty yeah yeah yeah 31 million youtube
channels
that's kind of wild so what is how many
pip how many have over
over a million yeah how many youtube
channels have over a million imagine
it's more
it might be twenty three thousand and
twenty four thousand
wow they're not even special no wow who
has the most subscribers
on youtube yeah do you know it i know
when like youtube was out in like 2006
there was something called like smosh
do you remember that comedian fred
pewdiepie oh we know i know i heard that
kid in the news 110 milly subs
a hundred so i understand if he just
like literally just turns on his camera
farts and turns it off he's making like
40 000 revenue i'm sure
i'm sure maybe even more i mean that's
the kid that opens up the presents right
pewdiepie let me see youtube career from
his college room
oh i i don't know so is he the most
famous you know what's crazy about
youtube
this person has 110 million subscribers
so i'm sure his
his uh viewer counts are in the billions
yes
yeah yeah if you walked up to many
people that aren't
that are like over 30 and they go you
know
pewdiepie you think he'd be the most
famous person on the earth
no but it's not like that like that's
more than a kardashian like
oh yeah no no i yeah i don't but it's so
kind of i guess esoteric you know yeah
yeah so i've been using that word too
much by the way i've
esoteric now i've i mean it's it i've
used that word
like three or four times in the last
month i gotta stop
too much but it's a lot about once a
week
where do you find yourself what kind of
conversation do you find yourself in
when you use esoteric so for example
you said ezzo no like i i could be wrong
i thought
i say esso but you you're putting a z in
there well it's eso
yeah is i could be wrong is it azo i've
been saying it's probably esoteric
esoteric you're right but say it how you
like so esso
so like for example yeah my mother
was talking to me the other day and we
were talking
about my other podcast the christy chaos
podcast and she said you know it's not
for me
really she said i like hey bae better
she told me that and i said well because
christy chaos is a little bit more
esoteric
esoteric and she said okay i understand
that
well i just felt because i thought
esoteric meant like
like it's for like a smaller group oh
okay i didn't think it meant that
i'm thinking esoteric means for oh
understood by only a small number of
people that's what
right because i'm in a specialized
knowledge or interest right because i'm
using phrases and
and things that like you know i'm saying
oh like you know because she's asking me
like what does it mean to be in the fog
chris i don't know what it means to be
in the fog and i'm like well that means
you're free open and gay
and she's like yeah these things are not
for me she's like i like to just sit
back and listen to you and sal talk and
laugh
i can understand she's like but i don't
know what some of the terms mean
but she was like i don't know who vin is
i'm like vin is jasmine that's
she she's giving birth to your
grandchildren so she's like yeah but i
don't know who they're more inside
baseball
yeah which you know sounds snooty and
it's not because it's all dumb
but but but but i've just found myself
saying as zotero too much and i it needs
to stop but
it's every time i get an even an inch to
use it
i say did you discover it recently or
just rebirth the new research i think i
discovered it recently did you hear it
people do that by the way i think it's a
phenomenon when people learn a new word
they
start throwing it around really yeah i
think so yeah yeah
so i i think i've i found esoteric
in i was getting a sandwich from the
deli
okay this is in la when i was back in
l.a okay
and i said jasmine had ordered
a sandwich and she wanted relish on it
and i said to jasmine
you know people don't like usually like
like
relish and the deli count this is true
and the deli counter guy said
relish is far more esoteric crowd
i don't know if he used that right
that's what he said that's what he said
and then so i remember thinking like i
think i know what it means but i
remember googling it
i was at jerry's deli on ventura
boulevard in l.a like it's it's it's a
niche it's
not everyone you need a taste for it
yeah maybe maybe he used a little bit of
poetic like
not jerry's daily by the way art steli
jerry's daily is closed i was at art
style
another great jewish deli jerry's famous
is where i met jerry seinfeld
are you serious nothing to do with
jerry's famous deli but that's where i
met him
interesting did i ever tell you that no
yeah i think i might have i i'm always
afraid i'm telling this
i i was eaten there just by chance and
and and it was it was it was
january 1995 and uh
and then uh when we walked in there was
two sheet cakes i said congratulations
seinfeld on your 100th episode
wow and uh we said what's this and the
waitress said well every week get to the
taping i think on wednesdays
uh the cast comes in here for to eat
every week
wow uh it's their ritual so this
right now they're filming the 100th
episode right now and uh
they're filming part of that and so
they're coming here to celebrate in a
little while
and i said well i just you know we clear
out the whole restaurant i said well i'm
gonna wait right outside and i waited
outside it started pouring and i weighed
in the pouring rain with a couple of
friends
and seinfeld pulled up never rains in
l.a never ever rains
wow and we must have been march it was
uh it was january january
moment ago it had to be a winter month
well january in la i don't know
but yeah so so we waited outside for
like an hour and people started filing
in and everything
and my friend dom who actually is the
same guy
remember i told him we faked running out
on the bill
and we jumped in his car and he was
peeling out dom d bartolomeo who owns
domenico's
italian special defense i mean so by the
way bet if you're ever in la
if you don't go to dominico it's i mean
i don't know what i'll probably go to
your head have you had it
tim dillon brought it to the house and
catered it for us it was unbelievable oh
good good the best yes dom told me
stuffed peppers i mean forget it
yes good thank you tim for and then he's
it's getting around now
it's unbelievable when i go back to la
i'm first first go
go to the shop and have some food in the
back room did you do that yet no no
tim brought it to us okay we never went
it's cool to go there and eat in the
back room you eat like the storage room
but you got a table back there for like
special guests
yeah and then i don't know if i'm a
special guest you're gonna have to make
a call no problem
yeah so uh where was i going with this
so i was with him
and my buddy mike and he's waiting
across the street in the car because it
was raining he didn't really care too
much
and i see him flashing the lights and
beeping from a parking lot of course
stream like he goes
he just walked past you we're standing
out there in the freezing cold
seinfeld pulls his porsche up parks
directly in front of the two doors
gets out walks and passes we missed him
what do you mean like direct like on the
curb
i was just standing on the curb directly
outside the entrance way to jerry's
famous nelly that i just finished eating
at
i ran to the bookstore i bought his book
so he could sign it for me
came back we're waiting in the rain
soaking wet
we have no one bro we've got hoods up
and then he flashes and we're just
waiting waiting no one's there people
are filing
and he goes he passed we passed you well
like what we turn around looking sure
[ __ ] he's in there already mingling
we're like oh now we've got to stay here
till he comes out
yeah yeah we only chose fans so imagine
you weren't
doing that he ended up coming out for a
cigar really yeah and uh
and it was just the valet him and us and
uh i said oh my god i said
uh i said we're huge fans we saw the
cakes we were eating here
we just figured we'd hang around maybe
we could say hello to you apparently you
walked right past us
when you came in he goes yeah i saw you
guys out here when i walked in we were
like oh
i said can i get a picture he goes sure
takes a picture of me i go
with a film camera wow it's on my it's
up on
you could you could pull it up i never
showed it to you no it's on it's on your
ignite baby it's on my ig but you could
also probably just put maybe
maybe you might just put my name in his
and maybe find a little quicker
right there left there it is let's see
it oh wow
look at that yeah look at me i mean how
old am i there 1995.
i am 19. wow i was january 95.
what were you doing in l.a what were you
doing in l.a at 18. 18.
first time ever on a plane and you went
all the way cross-country
because my friend dom what i just told
you about his cousin lived there who was
in a band called sister whiskey that
signed a million-dollar deal with warner
brothers records
had a hit album and a hit single and we
were like let's go hang out with jack
yeah and we went out there and it was
like a rock and roll band like a like a
it was like a tesla
like you know rock and we went out there
we stayed we crashed
on his floor for two weeks in l.a first
time i was on a plane and that happened
on that trip oh my god i was like 18.
and so i was really cool he signed the
book took a picture
and then and i did the worst thing i
didn't tell you any of this no
so guess what talk to me the united
states of america
we're number one in everything that's
the best country in the world shout out
to our fans listening in the uk and
abroad we love you too but america's
number one
now we're number one in meal kits oh
america's number one meal kit you must
be talking about hello fresh hello fresh
everybody hello fresh
they cut out the stressful meal planning
and grocery store trips because who
wants to go to the grocery
store anymore so you can enjoy cooking
at dinner on the table in 30 minutes
which is true
i've cooked for my family i literally
have gotten into relationship
issues because my girlfriend was like i
know you're having an affair with a
woman that's teaching you how to cook
because there's nobody cooking like this
i said babe it's hella fresh she goes
you're cheating on me with hella fresh i
said
i am well hello fresh bread and make
sure not to see your lady on the streets
because she will cut hella fresh she
will cut hello fresh if hellofresh
doesn't want to get a pair of scissors
to the neck
right they'll watch the back a little
just watch out hello fresh we know
you're doing a good service we know a
lot of people like you
but you don't want to piss the wrong
people off okay they have quick and easy
meals 15
20 minutes to make a dinner breakfast on
the go uh over 27 different recipes
this is for people who love to cook
people who want to learn to cook people
who don't have a lot of time to cook
you hear a lot about these services here
and there but i've been hearing mostly
about hello fresher taking this this
whole entire genre here by storm you
know it's barbecue season so i barbecued
a hello fresh craft burger the other day
unbelievable put a little guacamole on a
hell of a fresh semi it was i i felt
like i was in a cantina i was calling
myself chrissy cantina i'm in here
making mexican burgers with jalapenos
wow yes i love jalapenos go to
hellofresh.com
hey babe 12. yes and use the code hey
babe
12 for 12 free meals including free
shipping
this is the part that always gets me so
excited yes 12. where are you getting 12
free meals
where else are you getting 12 free meals
you understand that's like a day of
meals
yeah for me because i've been overeating
and you need meals to live
yes and they give you 12 of them for
free so let's say you're a normal person
eat three meals a day
that's four days worth of food they just
gave you four days and a lot of these
products you like opt-in
you don't need them a lot of this
product but you need yes you need
food to live yes absolutely why not get
free stuff
free living go to hellofresh.com hey
babe 12
use the code hey babe 12 for 12 free
meals including free shipping they give
you a meal for every day at christmas
just like in the song
12 days of christmas
just like in the song jingle bells
i hear a lot of people on the streets a
lot of people talking about cbd on the
streets uh-huh
yep a lot of people talking about cbd on
the streets it's it's it's all over the
place now yeah
but i pledge we pledge
hey babe pledges to only one cbd company
and that's sunday scaries you believe
this sunday scaries
i got some of the stuff from them they
sent me ice cream ice cream
the vanilla vanilla with the uh
creamsicle
the ice cream is fantastic i paired it
on the container
it says pair this with the sleep
tincture cbd
of uh sleepover we also sent yeah dude
it was
i had the best night's sleep my kid
missed school the next day because i
slept through
you did what's better than having a bowl
of ice cream and going straight to bed
unbelievable
and i didn't feel guilty about it i
wasn't expecting them to send me ice
cream but
no idea so nice i already am a big
enough fan of the cbd gummies yes the
unicorn jerky
the vegan af yes the tincture drops but
then all of a sudden they're throwing
ice cream at me unsolicited so now did
the ice cream they gave me cbd they gave
me ice cream they gave me gummies they
gave me vitamin b12 and d3 because they
add that to the product i'm like dude
you want to just be my mother
you could punch me square in the teeth
and i would smile that's how much cbd
i've been taking
i love it and you're gonna love it too
i'm telling you this cbd product is the
only one we advertise because this truly
is the best one and the fun packaging i
love it
go to sundayscaries.com use the promo
code hey babe
that's sunday scaries.com promo code hey
babe
25 off 25
miente cinco that's right that's one in
every four gummies is free
free right yes thanks sunday scaries for
making sundays chill again
absolutely don't get shook in 2021 don't
get shook at 2021 sunday scaries is
where it's at
i take him i go to church take him to
church
[Laughter]
we want to hear it i i was embarrassing
what would you do
he can't be worse than what you said to
david blaine
it was bad worse than blaine uh
no i didn't and we got to get the text
from shaquille o'neal okay yeah that's
right yeah so he walks
and then i won't even tell you the story
of the time i met ben affleck and jerry
seinfeld in a ben and jerry's go ahead
[Laughter]
that's a must
so he goes back in we run across the
street we're like okay we met him we
better
show him the autograph in the book we
jump it up and down and we're like man
i wish i said more to him like i knew i
was like encyclopedic
with my seinfeld knowledge at that point
i used to run home i used to
i used to deliver pizza my shift ended
at 11 but if there was really no calls
and i s and i mopped and put the chairs
up and closed down
i could usually leave by like 10 50 and
i only live five minutes from the
pizzeria
right seinfeld was on syndication at 11
o'clock
and this is before like tivo and all
that other [ __ ] so if you wanted to see
seinfeld you had to watch it then
you know it was still on thursday nights
but so i used to run home
at 10 50 try to get out of the pizzeria
early run home and on my vcr
push it in because i didn't know how to
do like the timing yeah because in vcrs
you could put a tape in and set a timer
and it used to start to
but i didn't know how to do it i mean
you're not you're not
stephen hawking who knows how to do that
i don't know who knows how to do that
nobody and i used to run home by the way
stephen hawking quadriplegic
shout out stephen hawking shut up shout
out r.i.p but he was a question
he did die he was a quadriplegic did he
die he passed away passed away
he was he was quiet he used to
communicate with uh straw yeah that's
right yeah
how did we lose him though what do we do
now with all his knowledge that we lost
wasn't he like someone who was like
people like i don't know ask hawking
yeah he was the he was one of the main
guys i don't i don't know
i don't know but he you know he lived a
great i mean he lived it was only three
years ago with als you know
he was supposed to be dead at 30 and he
lived this whole for many years and gave
a lot of information to science that we
didn't know yeah i hope he like rated
his journals
stephen's greatest scientific
achievement was discovery about black
holes in 1974 that shook the world of
physics according to
einstein's theory nothing including
light can escape
from uh inside a black hole that's why
it's black
i don't even understand the explanation
no i don't even understand it
no so anyway all right uh i thought if
light can't escape it'd be it'd be light
it'd be lit up
yeah but like how does it not escape a
black hole if the light goes in why is
it black wouldn't it light it up if the
light can't get out
what is what is protecting the black
hole from things coming out of the black
hole
a black hole is a place in space where
gravity pulls so much that even light
also
so gravity is pulling light back in wow
gravity is so strong because matter has
been squeezed into a tiny space
this can happen when a star is dying
because no light can get out
people can't see black holes
wow it's like space quicksand shout out
stephen hawking shout out hawks
yes shout out to yeah the atlanta hawks
who's probably going to beat the new
york knicks by now
oh and by the way what's that series at
3-1 hawks well not everybody's tom brady
am i right not everyone's tom brady
congrats to you
congrats to you winning yet another
super bowl 43 10 favorites
43 the oldest guy in the nfl can you
believe that yeah and he won it and
where was the super bowl
tampa absolutely written for him written
for him
but patrick mahomes keep your head up
congrats to you as well can't say enough
about the chiefs you lost this year but
who knows
kansas city chiefs um you got a strong
organization you got a strong foundation
there yes we're going to see that you're
going to be she's going to be going to
be around
they may have a different name and
different mascot but you the kansas city
football team
will be around for many years that's
right okay so
i say i wish i could have said more to
him because i wanted him to know again
i'm only 18.
it's my first flight so i'm just i
wouldn't do this now and i learned from
my mistakes but i said i really wanna
so it just so happens i guess he decides
to bail seinfeld so only a few minutes
after we see him
he's getting he's leaving again with his
coat on he's going and he's rounding the
the he's going on the outside in the
street to get back in his porsche i mean
my friend micah like oh my god we gotta
say this is the last time we'll ever see
him in our lives let's just say
something else to him
yeah and we're like jerry and he's
getting ah we're across the street it's
raining
and we're like jerry and we just start
yelling quotes from the show right
i mean embarrassing now i feel so
terrible right right and i'm like jerry
was there a second spitter and like oh
jesus references to the show
and he's like he was nice enough right
and then my friend's like
my friend freaks out a little bit and
then starts crossing the street to talk
to again so he starts crossing the
street
and we have a disposable windable film
camera oh my god
and jerry's like all right and he sees
this crossing the street again and you
can tell he like puts a little pep in
his step he jumps in the porsche
and closes it and it's like pouring rain
and we're just like
oh now what do we do so we still start
walking toward his car
and he's like all right guys all right
and then my friend's like yeah and then
my friend takes a picture of him
so here we have a picture of from right
outside jerry's car
of jerry in his porsche like with his
hand on the keys like looking at us like
this
it's all raining on his window and he's
just like and he just like peeled out
do we have that photo i will get it we
have to get that photo i got to get it
from that's a patreon
and you would think with all his money
he'd have a push to start but what can
you do what are you going to do
1998. sorry about that jerry if you're
watching and we know you are and we know
you
uh that's my bad i learned from that i
would never do that to anyone again it's
been done to me
yeah i understand now yes now shaq where
are we here
we go oh we got we have we're in the
shack zone okay
okay see shaq i didn't tell you this
shaquille o'neal famous basketball
player not from ireland no
pimp did i tell this okay we see shaq at
a lot of functions he had some shows on
our network just that the other yeah and
shacks around shacks around i think you
know what it was it was at the old
speaking of movie premieres grown-ups
grown-ups
okay shout out to movie premiere i'm
pretty sure
uh we we did some commercials and ads
for that
okay so we were invited to the premiere
and we i think it i think it was that we
see shaq
and he screams from across the theater
he goes fellas and we had never met him
before
but we're like oh he goes get over here
and he like gives us all hugs he's like
oh i love the show guys we gotta do
something together we're like yeah
definitely shaq you know he's like give
me your phone take my number
he says that wow so we're like all right
so cute gives them his phonetic area
code
l.a it was yeah
and he takes the number and he puts it
in and he's like all right boys and we
take our picture together and he leaves
i have that picture actually too okay
i gotta find it i have it it's us three
or four with him he's
two and a half feet bigger than oh my
god yeah and um
then we're like oh we gotta text him and
hang out he said it he took our phone
so we shouldn't feel whose number did he
take whose phone did he take he took q's
phone
okay and he put his number into q's
phone got it okay now
did he take q's phone do you think that
was because q was his favorite or was he
just standing closest
no no he didn't take his phone he's like
take my number and he was like so there
was no animosity amongst the group
because he took cue's phone and didn't
do you know what he didn't take his own
but he was like take my number and q was
like i got it
guys you had his phone he was quick with
the trigger was quick on the drill like
a horse named mcgraw
yeah he he he put it in yeah so q had we
all have it now he gave it to all of us
right but he gave that q gave that up
yeah
so so so now we're like oh when are we
gonna do it now now we wanted to do if
the opportunity had passed and we felt
that
it we took too long and now it would be
like a little bit out of nowhere yeah
and so
we never really texted him back so one
day we're doing good morning america
and we get to shout out gma saturday
yeah and shout out all morning show
shout out today's show
shout out regis and kathy lee shout out
regis and kelly shout out kelly and ryan
r.i.p regis regis r.i.p don rickles
r.i.p bob newhart
shout out to r.a.p r.i.p right so
he's on in the studio on live on the air
when we get to the green room we're like
holy [ __ ]
shaq's on gmail today this is the
perfect time
to text him yes so we just so says
it's shaq it's cue and shall on good
morning america right now we see the
around the studio we're in the green
room
just want to say hello maybe we'll see
in a couple of minutes yeah shaq goes
off
he doesn't come back we go out we do the
whole interview maybe he's not doesn't
look at his phone
who knows yeah we go out we do a whole
interview come out look
shaq hasn't texted okay so they had they
send cars when you're on these types of
trucks
right so which we're just talking about
this yes please send them a call for the
police i don't know yeah i mean they're
sending me metro cards over here come on
so so true true tv if you're watching
and we know you are i mean what are we
doing
get this guy his rental car uh you know
please host a backyard bar once over
here
so so we get in the car and we're
driving and we're like wow he never even
answers us maybe change his number
maybe but he gave us his number so it
doesn't make sense that he wouldn't
respond
we didn't like you know so sure as [ __ ]
we're in the car we're at a light it's
like 15 minutes after we left maybe 45
minutes after we texted him we gotta
text the check from shaq
he says sorry i swear to god i told you
this story never
no we wouldn't remember sorry fellas my
phone was in
dakar he spelled it d.a did he spell
fellas
f-e-l-l-a-s or what is he i think it was
with i think
i don't remember anything except
deviation with the thought to the doc
got it
sorry fellas phone was in dakar which
you just said yes uh
sorry i didn't catch up with you call me
let's hang out soon right
something like that something like to
the fact but i will see you soon stay in
touch something like that
and we're like whoa like he checked
those out he he responded yes he was on
us we could have done this a long time
ago we decided not to
his phone was in the car yeah he wasn't
not responding which is kind of a cool
move by you guys because you're like hey
i don't need shaq in my life it'd be
nice but like
dude i don't take it or leave you bro
you kind of gave them like the cold
shoulders
also cool in our own way maybe i don't
know yeah right so
so so now we're like well now we have to
respond you have to
so we're like what the hell do we so
what what you just said was going
through our mind
we don't want to overshoot it we don't
want to look desperate like we need to
hang out with you
right we want to be like yeah whatever
happens
the coolest way we can play it uh you
know not make it seem like we're like
like we weren't like like so nervous to
text them and so we were like
what would be the coolest most efficient
thing so we're not making a fool out of
ourselves
like i did with david blaine shout out
david blaine shout out magic shout out
illusions
yes shout out following your dream shout
out multiracial people that's right
puerto rican and jewish that's right as
i i told david blaine thank you for
the pleasure the shock and then all that
stuff right
so we didn't want to do that we want to
be way more efficient with our words and
we didn't want to uh what's the word
when they say we didn't want to gush
right gosh so shout out gushers good
snack
yeah yeah yeah yeah remember that gum
that yeah i think it's called freshen up
when you chew it and it just shoots in
here yes like there's like a
like like a what was it what would you
call that in there syrup
syrup yeah there's pink blue green and
you bit it in like the
syrup shot how did they make that
anymore ready for this one time i ate
into what's called the juicy lucy burger
in minnesota
into a juicy lucy they have cheese
molten cheese on the inside nobody told
me that i bit into it
i had a scar on my trach i burnt my
tonsil
wow pain like you can't imagine wow did
you take it up with them
yeah i said what you know this is like a
hazard and they're like the waitress
supposed to tell you
to not do what you just did but i mean
i'm talking about excruciating pain
yeah for a week no that's bad yeah
that's burning the roof of your mouth
one of the worst things ever yeah
the worst magic burning yourself no yeah
i can't even imagine it
go ahead pain every time you swallowed
every time i swallowed it felt like an
open wound in the back of my throat was
there anything that brought you any
relief
whatsoever sucking on ice cubes
yeah that's it that's it yeah all right
so here we go
we we hammond hall here about what to
write him back that will be the perfect
name
they'll be cool and won't look desperate
and what we netted out with was we
texted him back
word
one word one syllable you just wrote
back
one word we've never heard from him
again oh my god
word yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean you have
to text shaq again
i i should try to check should i see
when you say hey is this still you shaq
yes it's been so long it's been very
long hey is this still you shaq
like how often do you guys change your
numbers i haven't changed mine since 19
2004. i know chad says three months
what's that
chad says every three months chance
probably change his number every three
months he gets calls that are bizarre
wow when's the last time you changed
yours i'll say something right now my
landline i got when i was uh
i was at when i was 14
13. i still have it but where though
i don't use it it's disconnected it's
the same is that your mom's house
it's it's disconnected it's connected
but it's this like i don't
i never use a landline so it's like an
active thing that just will just ring to
nothing but yeah
when i moved out like in my mind i
transferred it because my mom moved into
yeah so i still have that number so it's
for 31 years i've had that number
wow yeah well but you connected it like
you were
when i was little it was my first i had
a i bought my own phone with an
answer machine with a little tape in it
you know what i mean like you know
appearance you remember that appears to
be like it's for you and then you get on
the phone and then
someone have to use it and be like hang
up mom well like yeah phone i gotta get
off my mamas he's the phone
so i started i got my own job and i paid
for my own but
yeah i once ruined a relationship with
my mother because
her boyfriend would always try to call
and i was on the phone
i mean for hours a day and and we only
had a landline and he said
you know when they broke up like in one
of the fights she was like and i can
never get in touch with you because your
stupid son is always on the phone
and she got offended that he called me
stupid even though my grade point
average wasn't good
yeah at the time so he kind of was
within his room but his mother heard all
she needed to know she was like i'm done
with you
but had i not been on the phone so much
and he would have gotten more in touch
with that could have been my stepdad but
he wasn't yeah but then she
then she upped she leveled up to the
santa claus
yes right gary gary yeah yeah gary
the mall santa yeah that was the guy
that wasn't the guy that came down on
you for being on the phone was he
no no the guy that came down and beat on
the phone was actually this was like a
thing that i had to go through when i
was 15
15 16 years old like imagine your core
group
imagine the the guys the jokers imagine
being a teenager you know guys friends a
teenager
imagine one of their dads dating
great song by the beatles yes it is also
uh also
yes also imagine dragons great band
um imagine one of their
dads dating your mom how frustrating and
uncomfortable that must have been
one of like imagine joe gatto's dad
which by the way in l.a used to drive on
joe gatto memorial highway all the time
you know how many times the texture
would be like i'm sorry to hear about
the loss of joe
but it's called the joe gatto ga tto
memorial highway in california i don't
know if you know if he knows that exists
he's got to know i was going to try to
probably another joe gatto maybe a
congressman
what does that mean but i would i would
multiple times try to take a picture of
it but i was going 70 miles an hour so i
couldn't
so whose friend was the dad that dated
your mother my one of my friends so i
had a core group of people
a core group of four or five guys and
one of their dads
started dating my mother for two years
two years so it's like i'm talking about
sal when when we would be like smoking
weed in a garage or they would be
smoking weed and i would just be
breathing in through contact or
you know having like you know a sane
eyeds or some type of wine cooler
because that's all you said i saw that i
was like that guy yeah so
somebody you know be talking joking
around you know talk about whatever and
then somebody just sounded nowhere back
hey what do you think mike's dad's doing
and somebody else back i don't know
probably banging chris's mom
you gotta be kidding me so and i would
get so mad at my mom and she's like well
you know i'm
happy with this guy and blah blah blah
and then when she called me stupid he
was out so i was so
excited when he got kicked to the
freaking curb because i was like at
least now
i can go back to my life where they're
not making fun of me every day
because his dad's dating my freaking mom
your friend of the
the son of the guy yes what's the name
mike
if you don't want to say it no yeah
mike's son was a good friend of yours
would he be like my my dad's having sex
with your mom like he would not he would
try to shield but he was also a couple
years older than me so he would
try to shield me from it but also like
get in on it and like because it's his
dad so it's like nobody cares about what
your dad's doing but he's like dude it's
my mom yeah you couldn't turn it around
unfortunately because the double
standards of society you can be like
dude my
your dad's getting my mom bro i couldn't
do this
away with your dad i couldn't do that no
it would be great to see like that play
out and they're all ripping on you like
you guys got it wrong
yeah yeah yeah i was like yeah my mom
i know for a fact my mom is strapping on
a strap-on
and banging your dad in the ass for a
fact
mike
yeah dude and then i mean yeah dude and
then
so that was i mean that was crazy
how we got there can you connect any
dots for us where do we go here i don't
know where we
this has been hey vape
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away
from your feelings babe don't be afraid
don't be ashamed don't hesitate to say
hey
babe hey babe hey babe hey babe
hey babe hey
you